well i think you you try not to worry  about it i mean you can't help but at  this point really  know that  that people are you know really uh  enjoy the show and love the show and  care about these characters one that one  of the you know the the things you may  you make this make this stuff uh for  yourselves  you know the season one season two we  got to you know share with folks and now  everybody not just those of us that work  on the show but anybody that watches the  show feels uncertain and enjoys the show  feels a certain bit of ownership and and  cares about these characters as much as  we do and you know that's a that's a  that's a plus in any in any situation um  so we're aware of it going on but we you  know try not to let it get in the way  too much  but we're aware of it oh yeah